[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work they
love and create amazing relationships
I'm George camel here with the man
himself Dave Ramsey this is your show
America that's my new title The Man
himself I like that I don't know what
himself is EP I'm always himself now
legendary now who knew wow open phones
here we want to talk to you about your
life and your money at
88255 225 that's
88255 225 Jason's with us in Hartford
Connecticut hey Jason welcome to the
Ramsey Show thanks Dave how you doing
today better than I deserve what's up
man okay um yeah I'm a long time uh
listener and I'm a Long Time Saver I was
hoping you could answer a question
regarding a retirement uh disagreement
between my wife and I um I'm 54 she's 51
um I'd like to retire next year at 55 I
feel like I have enough uh savings to
retire comfortably maybe possibly do a
side gig and um she doesn't feel like we
do so just asking for some advice well
retirement's not a feeling so that's at
least uh some consolation to you we can
look at some facts and data to go all
right do you have the the finances to
retire is your nest egg big enough how
much is your EG dude um around two and a
half around two and a half million so
she needs more than a couple hundred
thousand a year to live on uh apparently
so what's your current
expenses um you know right now we're
probably about $8,000 a month okay so
you need $100,000 a year to live and two
and a half million invested in good
mutual funds if it made 10% would be
250,000 right correct now you you
probably don't have access to all of
that at 54 do do you no she's she's
going to be younger so she will probably
work in and a half you can't access all
the 2 and a half million now at 54 years
old cuz some of it's in 401s right
correct some 59 and a half before you
get to it right have you got some money
to live on until you get to 59 and a
half well she can she she's actually
employed she's uh makes most of the
money in the household so what does she
make she she makes around 160 a year
okay and your expenses are 8,000 so if
you weren't even there she'd be okay
correct I think she's trying to tell you
something no she I I mean actually I I I
just want to get out the corporate okay
so I I yeah there's a couple things
mathematically the answer is you're just
fine and I just outlined why yep as soon
as you get access to two and a half
million if it's invested well if you
pull off eight or 10% of that a year
regardless of whether she's working you
easily you're going to make more than it
takes to cover your expenses right right
correct it's a math thing like George
said it's not a feeling but I think
there's a lot more going on here than
this well we're completely debt free we
have no credit card no I mean she
doesn't want you sitting on home on your
butt at 54 years old what it is no no
it's not the it's just going to be a
career change for me I'm I'm very handy
side hustle is different you know I want
to do I want to retire and do a side
hustle I it's not a side hustle it's a
business retire and open a business okay
well we'll call it a business yeah let
start a small business idea that makes
more than you used to make in corporate
yep and then then none of this is an
issue so I I just can't recommend I'm 63
and I can't recommend you do nothing
it's not worked out for most of my
friends they die no I'm not going to do
anything trust me we have a younger son
that I actually want to spend the
Summers with so the home the the
business would give me the flexibility
to schedule work based on his school
schedule so if he was home in the
Summers I could spend more time with him
so this is kind of a work life balance
thing for
me yeah um you have the money to do
whatever you want I'm I'm now moving
from Financial to life do something okay
babysitting your kid in the Summers
going from the with the net worth you
have is your only goal and calling that
life balance and making it sound cool is
it's going to wear pretty thin quick
dude you're going to want to go do
something with your life and you're too
young to do nothing you you're too
valuable in the marketplace so go do
something with your life that's just guy
to guy right there there has nothing to
do with the math the math is you're just
fine and I'm think I kind of think in
this argument with your wife she's a
little bit worried about
that um I don't think so because I'm
pretty um I'm pretty involved in all
kinds of activities and Civics and
that's not the same thing well I have a
lot of activities to keep me busy that's
for sure that's not the same thing I'm
talking about being being of marketplace
value not simply serving the
JC's okay um and so you can do whatever
you want to do I'm not I'm not
belittling you for that I'm I'm just
trying to listen to what's going on here
because there's nothing in this math
that says you can't quit cold today all
the math says you can quit well the
issue for her is she just doesn't think
we have enough that's the thing she's
just worried that we're going to run out
M have you shown her the expenses and
the net income and what the retirement
accounts will do yeah we've already met
with a planner and he says we're good to
go as well so well then she just doesn't
believe the data at that point lady lady
that makes $160,000 a year is not stupid
so what is she really saying that's I'm
trying to figure out no she's just she's
she's always she's come from a family
where everybody works no that she didn't
come from a family where math didn't
work math Works in All Families she
doesn't believe the math I'm telling you
well that that then that's a different
issue but she's not too stupid to
believe the math she's not wanting to
believe it for some reason and that's
your core issue it's not do I have
enough to retire it's how how do I deal
with my situation so I I have a friend I
talked to the other day he was one of
he's like the sixth guy to ever go
through financial University wow he
called me up and I met with his grandson
that's how long ago this was right met
with his grandson the other day who's a
a millionaire because this guy went
through Financial Peace University
pretty cool so um but the first time him
and his wife walked in she was a real
estate agent and they had $4 million
they were in their 50s and she thought
she she worked like 80 hours a week so
on real estate she could not relax and I
sat down with the math and I showed her
the exact same math that he had been
showing her that $400,000 year 30 years
ago $400,000 a year 30 years ago you
know you you've got enough you don't
have to be in freakout mode she relaxed
calmed down ended up selling more real
estate cuz she was in freakout mode all
the time and but it was there was
something it was an emotional thing like
with Jason's wife because Jason's wife
the lady I'm talking about is not dumb
she's brilliant and Jason's wife not
dumb they don't generally pay dumb
people 160 grand for much of anything
generally not for long anyway it catches
up with you being dumb
but the uh but but the the is it the
security gland that flaring up could be
it could be scarcity mindset potentially
like I knew a guy that was a billionaire
and I asked him why he worked all the
time and he said I grew up dirt poor and
I'm like well I I get that and he goes
no like the dirt the floor in our house
was dirt wow that's dirt poor in
Appalachia and he goes I can't get that
out of my system so I work all the time
like that's that's not a math problem
that's not a financial problem that's a
psychological problem you have a wound
from your past a trauma that you've not
overcome M and and that's a Dr John
deloney answer it's not a George camel
Dave Ramsey answer right yeah well a lot
of that has to be dealt with if you're
going to ever think it's enough cuz
point you you got 20 million you go this
guy this guy had a billion could all go
away at any time so I got to keep
stacking keep stacking yeah and and
listen you you can't get enough
godliness with contentment is great gain
Financial Peace two words that don't go
together like Airline service right this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
right
George camel Ramsey personality soon to
be number one bestselling author we've
launched the new book is my co-host
today Breaking Free from broke the uh I
actually am holding one the real that
they real came in when I got here they
were on my desk they're pretty cool man
this is the real book it's coming out
January but it's in Pre sale right now
Breaking Free from broke the Ultimate
Guide to more money and less stress on
pre-sale right now in the store along
with a lot of other wonderful ramsy
goodies Rachel's uh new book is about
sold out we've got a order another order
coming in WoW uh the children's book
it's gone crazy I'm glad for what I have
great one yeah that's what the book is
called and we're glad that it's selling
thank you I'm glad for what I have
another bestseller well you post you
posted a great picture of you with the
grandkids reading the book and I think
that pulled everyone's heartstrings I
don't know if I was reading I think I
was just kind of hanging out yeah was I
reading it well it was a pose photo I
imagined you reading yeah it was Rachel
yeah I'm sure the kids love when you
read to them I yeah it's great Papa Dave
St read The Total Money Makeover to
those Papa Dave stories are a big deal
man I'm just saying epic because I just
make up stuff Justin's in Washington DC
hey Justin what's going on hey how you
doing sir better than I deserve how can
we
help so uh I'm I'm active duty military
um and I have a decent am of credit card
debt along with debt in general um and I
really am trying to figure out how I can
start knocking this debt off um and and
eliminating this um you know because
it's become a bit of a burden and I
honestly don't even know where to start
cool how old are
you I'm uh 28 cool how much debt you
got um between uh house credit card
Vehicles were about uh 350 how much of
that
house uh
290 okay so you got 60,000 how much of
that
cars uh about 30 to 40 okay so you got
30,000 in credit card
debt uh roughly roughly 28 yeah okay all
right wow thanks for your service which
branch you serve in uh I'm currently
Army sir okay cool thank you very much
how long you been in uh I've been in
about six and a half years about long
enough to make this mess
yeah yeah um
unfortunately okay and you're ready for
a change the payments have caught up to
you and you guys are feeling the weight
of these and you want
out yeah yeah what's your household
income um between my wife and I um we're
about 100,000 great so you make a 100
you owe 60 in this Consumer Debt so the
question is how much margin can we
create to throw extra on the debt and
we're going to follow the debt snowball
method that's the way 10 million people
have followed it the same way I got out
of 40 Grand in debt and so you have how
many debts three or is it more than that
total between the car loans and the
credit card is it multiple
cards uh no it just it's One credit card
and honestly I really didn't even want
to get a credit card to begin with
fortunately but you know when you become
a homeowner it's one of those things
that where you you got to have it as
like a backup plan well backup plan
would be your own money like having an
emergency fund where you become the
money money would be a backup plan debt
turn out to be a good backup plan 20%
interest on 30 grand is a bad plan for
sure yes absolutely okay so how much are
you okay so we're going to list the debt
smallest largest you have one big credit
card one big car and that's it other
than the house is that it uh yes and I
have a one of my cars is paid off
already yeah um and then I do have a
motorcycle uh that's uh or alone 10,000
right now okay all right and what did
you say the household income was again
uh we're about 100 a little under
100,000 it's like 98 and some change
okay Justin when I was exactly your age
I filed bankruptcy that was 30 years
ago about 35 years ago now um so I know
how it feels to be scared and broke and
um after that I figured out how to get
out of debt and stay out of debt and I
figured out that it was worth it to
sacrifice now I call it live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else the way you're living
life now is all the money comes in all
the money goes back out and there's
nothing left but
stress so we um after each paycheck we
we still pocket
about anywhere from 1,500 to 2,000 yeah
okay a month after after all our bills
if I woke up in your shoes knowing what
I know now and today I'm a
multi-millionaire because I quit doing
stupid crap or as much I limited the
stupid crap I do right
and so what if I woke up in your shoes
I'm going to give you a real harsh
prescription because I know that the
faster you get out of this mess the
faster you're going to actually become
wealthy you see the ratio of
that yes sir okay so
um anyway uh I would sell my motorcycle
today it's a freaking toy you don't need
it you can get your motorcycle later by
the way I have several things with
wheels and Motors in them now but I
didn't have them when I was broke and so
you live you drive like no one else so
that later you can drive like no one
else you're driving a $30,000 car I
probably consider selling that and
moving down but if you want to plow your
way through it you got $60,000 worth of
debt and if you do that at $22,000 a
month that's 30
months right two and a half years you're
not you don't need to see the inside of
a restaurant and you don't need to go on
vacation the only time you're in the
inside of a restaurants if somebody you
love is working there and you're getting
a free
meal and that might be you but I don't
care nobody is going anywhere except
we're getting out of debt we're living
on beans and rice rice and beans we're
going to clean this freaking mess up and
we're never going back in debt again
because if you didn't have any payments
but a house payment right now man you'd
have some money and you deserve to have
some money because you have put in your
time serving your country you don't
deserve to be this
broke absolutely
sir now will you this is going to boot
camp that's what I'm doing you hearing
me yeah absolutely and uh so I actually
do have my motorcycle up for sale right
now good you're decision that um what's
it list for decision that um so after
all the aftermarket stuff I put on it um
I'm trying to sell it for about 10 um
and you know yeah so I figured if I if I
can get maybe a little bit less maybe
9500 you know I can put the yeah you can
cover it or a little bit more and you
have 500 to throw with the credit card
chop the credit card up get your wife on
a budget you two sit down and get the
every dollar app out it's completely
free to download it and use it it's the
number one budgeting app in the world go
check it out and sit down and lay
yourself out of budget and commit to
boot camp for the next 24 to 30 months
and you could be dead free but the house
and then that sets you up with a lot of
money in your pocket to do a lot of
stuff with in generosity in investing
and to begin paying off your house yeah
there's a lot of sacrific you can make
if 30 months sounds like a long time
let's sell more stuff let's increase the
income let's get the expenses down
Donna's in Wilmington Delaware Donna
what's
up Hi how are you sir better than I
deserve how can I
help well um I'm just checking with you
I've been listening to you for about two
months checking with you to see if I'm
making the right decision my husband and
I are seniors uh we're retired we own a
house in in Delaware one in um Lewis
which is near rington and and a rental
property in rovus and my son lives in
Connecticut and we're considering of
buying a third home up there instead of
visiting him and paying hotel rooms all
the time uh buying a house and making it
into an Airbnb in this way we can use it
when we want and rent it out when we can
the two houses down here are fully paid
off uh and our rental property pays the
expenses for our house here which is a
good thing but it would mean having to
go into debt when we go to
Connecticut uh don't have much money for
a down payment so we'd have to mortgage
the whole thing and we're looking for no
more than about 250 to 300,000 for house
up there yeah I just don't want in my
60s to make a wrong decision yeah it's a
wrong decision the road eating cat food
after I it's a wrong decision don't do
it you don't spend $250,000 of borrowed
money to avoid a hotel
room no well eventually no not
eventually you're not right that's what
exactly what you're
doing and and then you got to screw with
Airbnb people Lord help
you have you ever rented Airbnb
people not now you're running a
hotel oh yeah that's a total pain in the
butt this is going to be a big headache
and it's going to cost you guys a lot of
money and it's going to cost you your
piece just just rent you a hotel room
honey I mean you go rent the freaking
Four Season suweet in the corner for a
lot less than this and pay cash for it I
mean just go you know no no if you can't
pay cash for uh Toys don't buy toys and
this is a
toy now Donna we love you if that
sounded harsh I apologize I'm coming up
on a commercial break and I wanted to
tell you the truth cuz I love you this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
thank you for joining us America open
phones at
88255 225 I say America I just came back
from an overseas vacation in Egypt and
um I'm shocked as to how many people in
other countries they recognize
everywhere we go listen to the show it's
cuz your co-host is half Egyptian so now
I'm I'm bringing a whole new market to
you Dave that's that's it they were like
the George C you know George camel that
guy you're the guy with George camel
that's what they kept saying Yeah that's
what they told me over and over I'm sure
you stand out like a sore thumb there
too it doesn't help an old yeah lots of
sore thumbs yeah that's that's a that's
a yeah in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt-free stage Brandon and
Hannah are with us welcome guys what's
up where do you guys live uh we live in
a small town called Mount Dora just
outside of Orlando awesome welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off a
whopping
143,000 110
$110,000 whopping you almost scw it
there yeah all right and how long did
this take uh four years on the dot all
right and making what kind of household
income range of income uh when we first
started our debt free Journey
collectively we were making $48,000 uh a
year M uh at the end uh currently where
we are we're making about $1
143,000 uh a year nice jumping four
years yeah yeah very well done what do
you guys do for a living uh I am a
corporate recruiter for an insurance
technology company there we go and I
work on our corporate marketing team ah
and we work for the same organization
actually shocking is that where you met
no high school oh okay High School yes
all right how long have you been
married years in January oh okay so you
started this separately and then
finished it together absolutely so uh
what kind of debt was the 110,000 and
whose fault was most of
this there's always
one uh well I think uh we had $73,000 in
student loan debt my student loan
debt uh which became hours um we had uh
uh what was it $185,000 of credit card
debt and then we were paying back an
auto loan that my grandparents had
purchased a car for us when we were
really needed one and we wanted to pay
them back as soon as possible oh okay
yes and I want to emphasize that the
$73,000 was just for my bachelor's
degree okay all right and and what's
your degree in uh communication
specifically in public relations and
advertising and now you work in
marketing so that's good you're actually
using your degree you're it's unusual
wonderful good for you good stuff well
what started this journey guys uh Dave
uh four years ago I called into your
show and I was I nice you were very nice
I was in a a pickle had five credit
cards maxed out up to my eyes in uh
minimum payments and I was considering
debt consolidation but the bad kind
where you you know default on all of
your loans and then your credit score
tanks and everything goes out of whack y
you talked to me out of it sent me a
copy your Total Money Makeover read it
cover to cover a few times and uh you
know got on the program and then got her
along with me wow that's the best way
are they now story ever one of one of
those free books actually worked George
amazing that one worked good sometimes
they work sometimes they end up in the
trash I'm never talking to that guy
again but you took the advice and you
inspired others and here you guys are
together was it easy for you to get on
board Hannah did you already know about
this stuff so actually no um when he
first presented it to me I was like I
know how to save money you know I'm
making my own money I'm an adult
whatever but he broke it down into such
a fun way especially following a lot of
your practices after reading the book we
even incorporate you know now we have
monthly budget meetings that we follow
the budget um document that's on your
website I believe oh yeah very good old
school I like it very well done
congratulations we uh actually were able
to cash flow her entire master's degree
oh wow um which was excellent she didn't
believe it was possible but I broke down
the numbers like he we can do this um
what's your Master's in my masters is in
public relations so and that helped me
actually get a big bump in my pay I bet
so it already arei very good yeah now
that that's called smart education I
like smart education there's too much
dumb education out there that's smart
well you actually want to hang the
degree up when it's paid for when you
got student loans attached to it you're
like I'm going to hide that in a closet
well they can repo it so you know what
I'm
doing way to go guys yeah how's it feel
to be free I
like a literal weight off your shoulders
I didn't think the psychological benefit
was going to be as powerful as it has
been but it's it's been phenomenal uh
one of the things and I I would say this
is probably the hardest thing we did but
shortly after getting married uh last
January um we took all of our honeymoon
money all 12 $133,000 and threw it at
debt and uh had to postpone our trip to
Italy but we were finally able to take
it earlier this year all right yay
that's a good very good well nice Honey
great photos too if you're watching on
YouTube it's fantastic the Italy photos
that's the perfect yeah the Coliseum
yeah good delayed gratification right
there you guys still took the trip you
know a lot of people think well I Dave
doesn't want me to live my life and we
go no you can live it two years from now
with freedom you're not paying for that
trip six months later you guys did
exactly that yeah unfortunately also uh
this year I was laid off in in uh
February and fortunately because we were
smart and had a a cushion between us and
life it was it was a lot easier to go
through that Not freak out like we would
have few years ago yep every $5 out of
the N that we make in monthly um went to
our savings and just Bud like going to
the debt at first and then after we
finally got debt free it is now just
become a nice NES a as our six month
emergency fund yeah how old are you too
29 and 28 all right not even 30 years
old you paid off $110,000 in debt and
four years of that you've been married
two years and you're working it
separately before that well done what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is cuz you're a blazing example
you did it I'm so proud of y'all
thanks um I I would say 100% it is worth
it um unfortunately the systems in place
can kind of make you feel like it's
hopeless in America but you can
absolutely do it especially speaking to
the younger audience and talking to the
people in their 20s and 30s uh you can
do it um just perseverance dedication
staying consistent and and being honest
with yourself and I think a biggest
thing too is simplifying it and
communicating it it's so scary to talk
about finances if you don't know what
you're talking about but with tools like
your money Total Money a book every
dollar we use that all the time you know
it just made it so much easier and we
were able to just really focus dig our
heels in and get to our goals and I'm so
happy we've done it now in our mid to
late 20s and we never have to look back
and listen there were moments where you
know we're just putting money towards
this debt and it's just like this is
never going to end like I'm sick and
tired of throwing my money into this
NeverEnding black hole and it was just
absolutely worth it you worked two jobs
in the beginning yeah for almost two
years I worked two jobs with like a day
off every week just to get ahead what
what was the best money you made at a s
gig uh at my previous organization I
worked for the Airlines and uh they
commissioned bonus checks to us
depending on how well we were doing
during the flight so just hustling like
that and then just finding something
easy to do on the weekends ah okay all
right good very cool
very cool way to go you guys thanks what
a great job I can tell you guys have
built these muscles where you're like
any Financial goal we're going to be
able to do it cuz you know how to save
you know how to spend wisely and that's
the most hopeful part of all this you
guys are invincible now yeah and and
honestly like this is four years in the
making it has taken us four dedicated
years to be here today and it it's did
did some of your friends like think
you're were cuckoo yeah 100 friends
family yeah a lot of cuckoo out there
yeah yeah some people are like don't
worry just pay the minimums on the de
forgiv stay in Deb it'll all work out no
it won't this is called grownup stuff
yeah way to go you guys it's so good
that's so good so now you get to do the
Toby Keith thing How You Like Me Now
right oh my gosh I love that song we
just hope we can Inspire other people
out there to do this cuz I I promise you
it's worth it you just did my brother
well done very well done hey we've got a
copy of The Total Money Makeover for you
to give away in the live and give box
and of course the b the baby steps
Millionaire's book cuz that's your next
step in this journey you're going to be
there for sure and a Financial Peace
University membership so enjoy those or
give them away as our gift thanks for
coming all the way up from Florida to do
your debt free scream you two are
incredible Brandon and Hannah Orlando
Florida area 110,000 paid off in four
years make it 48 to 143 they did it
before their 30 count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream all right all right 3
2 1 we're de
free
yeah that's how it's done right there
woo love it this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
chef
[Music]
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is is my
co-host today open phones atle
8825 5225 our question of the day comes
from our friends at neighborly your hub
for home services for over 40 years
neighborly has done an exclusive network
of trained local service providers
backed by the neighborly Done Right
promise so if it's not done right
neighborly will make it right visit
neighborly dcom Ramsey and you can learn
more today's question comes from Peter
in Michigan hey Dave I just turned 22
and have a credit score of 730 oh God
I'm looking to buy my first home within
the next year but the interest rate on
homes are through the roof although I
see that they are coming down a little
bit should I hold out for lower rates go
ahead and lock it in thank you aha the
classic conundrum should I time the real
estate interest rate Market it's kind of
like timing the stock market the best
timeing to invest in the stock market is
when you have the money to invest versus
trying to figure out if it's going to go
down or up exactly so I would buy when
he's ready to buy yeah marry the house
date the
rate so buy the house and refinance when
rates come down you're not married to
the mortgage you're married to the house
so figure out the right house at the
right time the right girl at the right
time get married and date the rate the
rate's temporary it's not a permanent
decision so no one says you have to keep
a mortgage so matter of fact I have a 0%
mortgage I don't have one
I haven't had one in years not a percent
not even a mortgage so there you go and
uh that's a possibility too in your
future um so I will tell you this Peter
you're 22 you got plenty of time there's
no problem you'll get there but whenever
you're ready to buy marry the house and
date the rate and and you just you can
refinance you can refinance any of you
that are sitting there right now waiting
on house prices to come down you're
going to be
waiting you're going to be waiting
there's some prices that have adjusted
but values have not adjusted prices have
adjusted because some of these people
were trying to get some of these people
who were paying too much because
everything was in a frenzy you remember
right after the fouchy pandemic y'all
remember that yeah right after was
listed for a b jillion dollars and uh
the market was like no we're not paying
that you were looking for a sucker and
the sucker didn't come so now they
dropped their price but the values have
not gone down and so and they're not
going to go down cuz there's a shortage
of housing buyers are not out there
eating up everything right now and
there's not a lot of
inventory and so it's just it's a really
slow market number one but it's slow in
listings too you can't find a property
because there's not a lot of inventory
so uh it's a really weird time to buy
but there's nothing wrong with buying
right now if you wait two years the
price is going to be more and if you buy
now at a higher rate and the rates come
down you just refinance that's the whole
thing Ashley's with us in Philadelphia
hi Ashley welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's
up so my boyfriend is receiving a pretty
large settlement um in the next coming
months and we're kind of debating uh
we're looking to buy our first home um
and obviously once the home comes uh
once the right home comes we'll we'll do
that but he's stuck on paying the house
out in full um and I'm wondering if it's
better to do a big down payment and get
a mortgage on the house why do you want
a
mortgage I don't I don't know I feel
like putting a huge lump of that
settlement into a house why do why do
you want a
mortgage I I'm not I'm not sure well you
just told me you wanted a
mortgage what do you think you should do
with
it I I just want him to use it as wisely
as possible um it sounds like he wants
to avoid how much how much is he getting
yeah um right around half a million okay
and how much is the house price you're
thinking about
buying um we were thinking like mid
threes okay all right um is the
settlement
taxed no it's not okay all right
um well let me uh send him a warning
through
you and you're not going to like this
okay okay there is no we you're not
married exactly yeah's a he coming I'm
coming into it yeah exactly there's a he
it's his money and so if he buys a house
it goes into his name not our
name unless you're married are y'all
getting
married um eventually we've been
together for six years so apparently
apparently not okay so um I mean six
years and you pain painter get off the
ladder I mean so you've already figured
out what you're doing but the um yeah I
if I'm him what's his what is his
income um right around uh 55 I think
okay so let's pretend for a second let's
just reverse engineer this so that
you'll it'll help you with your heart on
understanding where our voice advice is
coming from let's pretend that he made
$55,000 had $200,000 in the bank and a
paid for $300,000 house
and you walked up to that guy and you
met that guy he had a paid for $300,000
house2 200,000 in the bank he makes
$55,000 a year would you then tell him
to go get a mortgage because that's
wise no same thing though isn't it m I
just did it
backward yeah it's the same exact thing
so the only thing that that could fall
under the heading of wisdom is if you if
it made sense and I don't think it does
and Georgia doesn't think it does to
borrow on your home to do
investing and effectively if you're
going to invest some let's say he put
100,000 down and instead of paying the
other 200 on the house put it in mutual
funds okay which is kind of what's
probably rattling around in the back of
your head somewhere um I if if that
makes sense then borrowing on the paid
for house to do the same thing would
also make
sense but by reverse engineering hearing
it it makes you realize oh there's risk
involved here what was the can I know
you can't get into lawsuit details was
he injured for the settlement he was
yeah okay all right is he
okay he's yeah he's great now he can
still work no permanent damage to his
income no no it was it was a a miracle
heal good good I'm glad for him and you
too yeah so I would tell him to pay cash
for his house and and set aside an
emergency fund and invest the balance
long term and by the way if you don't
have any payments in the world and you
make $55,000 you could pay what's the
equivalent of a house payment into your
Investments every month and that alone
will make you a millionaire in just a
few
years okay does that make sense too it
does it does yeah yeah so that's what I
would do but
um uh
yeah those of you that are uh uh
shacking up and playing house or
whatever you want to call that stuff um
be sure that you keep your legal stuff
completely
separate and you have to be careful even
with your pronouns in this case not like
woke pronouns but like pronouns like the
you have to get your we are buying a
house we're buying a house we aren't
doing anything he
is we're getting a settlement no he is
if you're married there's a Wei when
you're married you become French we
right that's how that works but until
you're married there's not a we um
legally I'm talking about um and
and honestly asley that also leaves you
in a
uh a predicament as well that I don't
want you in I would rather you have the
safety in this relationship and the
things that you've been pouring into the
the economics you've been pouring into
this for six years I'd rather you have
the safe safety of marriage marriage
represents safety for you young lady so
I I I would just as a you know a guy
who's seen all the stuff go bad because
that's all we do we work with a lot of
people who where things went bad I I
want I want you to have a better life
than then this is setting up cuz you
know one day he just decides you're not
there legally he didn't have to do
anything except tell you to move he
didn't even have to evict you you don't
even have tenants
rights you just move out you're a
squatter you know no equity nothing and
that's just um you know you don't want
to play that out for 90 years you don't
want to play that out I've been married
43 years you don't want to play that out
43 years and see how that looks it
doesn't this doesn't age well it's like
cheap wine it doesn't age well so you
know that that's just me loving you
right now telling you that for you so
you guys do whatever you want to do
you're grown-ups and we love you either
way we'll help you all the time you call
us anytime this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones at
88255 225 I'm Dave Ramsey your host
George camel ramsy Personality YouTube
celebrity is my co-host today his uh
YouTube show George camel just surpassed
the first 100,000 subscribers we got the
little YouTube button in we got the
whole little plaque they send you when
you hit 100,000 placky poo very kind to
all the subscribers out there and people
watching every week the fastest show to
go to 100,000 in the Ramsey Network on
YouTube did it faster than anybody I'm
not very fast in life so that's nice
that I beat uh beat y'all to something
Dave hey you got there quick the team
has done an incredible job making this
entertaining fun and of course
informative and helpful Casey is with us
in Amarillo Texas to start this hour hi
Casey welcome to the Ramsey Show hey
Dave and George how are you better than
we deserve brother what's up well I'm a
little embarrassed because this is
really going to Showcase my ignorance of
the subject but I've got a few questions
about the national debt I don't know if
I don't know if you've heard but we are
in debt a little bit the rumor yep so
I've got three questions for you okay
the first one is who do we owe this 33
trillion to the second one is why as a
country did we borrow it in the first
place and the third one is is it even
possible or logical for our federal
government to pay off this debt and
operate debt free those are great
questions um well who we owe the money
to or whoever bought the treasury bills
are called t bills and the treasury of
the United States issues a
bond and if you buy that Bond then that
means that if I bought a I don't know
$100,000 treasury bond that means the
United States of America owes me
$100,000 if I bought that Bond and it
pays me a certain interest rate now I
know they're never going to pay the bond
uh or if they do they're going to pay it
by issuing another
one yeah okay which is if it actually
ever does come due that's how they do it
they'll issue another set to cover the
ones that are coming due but I also know
that I can sell that Bond at any moment
because the uh the credit rating of the
United States of America is still strong
okay so that's how they finance it and
the danger is when foreign countries or
uh foreign entities of any kind wealthy
uh corporations in foreign in in foreign
countries buy up a bunch of that that
means the United States is in debt say
to China as an example deeply in debt to
China it's a little dangerous uh
politically uh but it's not like they
can call the debt it's not like they can
repo Kentucky so it's you know it's okay
so but um in that sense it's not
dangerous but it's just kind of creepy
you know what I'm saying so your second
question was can or your third question
was can we ever pay it off your second
question was
what oh why why did we go in debt well
we went in debt because just CU like
normal like regular human beings they
spent more than they
made when the revenue coming in from
taxes and other things won't cover the
expenses of Highways and Military and
$45,000 toilet seats and a billion
dollars to this country and $8 billion
to that country in
supplies um which we do pretty regularly
give billions and billions and billions
away overseas when we don't have the
income in a year the amount that we're
short revenue is sure is not enough
Revenue to cover the the outgo the
budget the difference is called the
deficit and uh the amount that we borrow
has gone up every year because we keep
going F we keep uh spending not just
spending more than we make but every
year spending more than the more than we
make we raise the amount that we're
going into that so when they say they
cut the deficit all that means is is
they didn't go over budget quite as much
that's all it
means you know so it's kind of it's kind
of an oxymoron on Words and then the
last question is can we uh get rid of it
mathematically we could I don't think we
have the political um willpower to do
it because as soon as you tell
um your Uncle Henry who gets a
a subsidy because he runs a dairy farm
from the US government that he's not
going to get that subsidy anymore
because we're cutting our expenses then
he's not going to vote for that
congressman and that congressman is
going to get get replaced by a
congressman who will spend money like
he's a drunken
Congressman right yeah and so the people
won't they don't they they want to they
they in theory a lot of people say I'd
like to balance the budget I'd like to
get the the income to at least equal the
where we're not going further in debt
but to do that would require cutting a
lot of things out and the problem is
we're so far in debt now that a big
portion of the budget is just the
interest on the old
debt right and you can't cut that you
got to pay that so where are you going
to cut you're going to cut giving um you
know money in the Middle East money in
the Ukraine uh money to this country
money to that country there's a lot of
people talk about that uh are you going
to cut the military I mean those people
don't get paid anything anyway and they
put their lives on the line for us I
don't know how to do that uh it just
requires this
tremendous um the amount
of hate that it would generate because
of the number of lives it would touch to
cut everything necessary to cut to get
it down to balance would I don't know if
anybody's got the political Capital to
pull that off either side I think it'd
be the be the last time that party
existed uh right now cuz people have
gotten used to being being on the
government Dole one way or another you
know they're used to the the local
government in my county is waiting on $4
million right now to build a highway or
to redo a road that runs up beside one
of my houses and they've been waiting 5
years on that $14 million from the
federal government and they won't build
the road until the $4 million comes
meanwhile the road's a damn damn goat
track you know it's awful but but but
every and so they're waiting on $14
million from the government instead of
the local County handling their own
business wow and that it goes that it's
that way everywhere that times a
thousand you know waiting on waiting to
do the bridge repairs until we get the
the government money waiting to do this
until you get the government and so
everybody's on the dead gum take and
nobody wants to say no and saying no is
the only way you balance a budget and
when you do it at home Cas see when I do
it at home the way I live on less than I
make is I look at the kids and I say no
I look at my wife and look and we look
at our budget and we go we can't go on
vacation we're broke people we got to
not be broke people before we can go on
vacation we can't afford that car uh
those bass are going to get away cuz I'm
not going to have a bass boat with a
motor that big cuz I can't afford to pay
for it this is what normal people do we
say no but the federal government has
absolutely no ability to say no because
everybody wants them to say yes yeah so
that's the problem it's not a math
problem you could actually cut taxes and
revenues go up art laugher proved that
under Reagan it's a statistical fact
it's not a political Theory
so it actually worked the re you see
Warren Buffett's method to solve this
yeah great quote absolutely yeah I said
I could end the deficit in 5 minutes you
just pass a law that says anytime
there's a deficit of more than 3% of GDP
all sitting members of Congress are
ineligible for reelection there you go
you lose your job unless you fix this
yeah there's one way to do it because
you read to find what winning looks like
what does winning look like as a
congressman now giving everybody free
money and if you made it what when the
only way you can stay is if you balance
the budget that's a new way of saying
what winning looks like hanging out with
lobbyist they would learn the new
ancient word the ancient word
no no you press your tongue towards the
roof of your mouth you release and let
air go by
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel is my co-host today I'm
Dave Ramsey your host hey if you like
this show you can help us out we'd
appreciate the help by the way we do
need all the help we can get around here
uh subscribe click the Subscribe button
click the follow button click the like
button share the show send somebody a
link or some some of the different
podcast venues or platforms some of the
different YouTube things you can they
have a share button where you can just
click it share it real easy with
somebody hey I like that clip I like
what they're doing there you're you're
the only marketing we have so thank you
and you've been sharing it and telling
people about it we know because our
numbers are way up way up and we
appreciate that because you guys are
sharing it and subscribing and doing all
the proper things we appreciate you
that's the way you say thanks here
otherwise it's just free hey pretty cool
Elizabeth's in Miami hi Elizabeth
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help um so let me
start with um my dad just passed a
couple months ago I'm sorry and um I
help my mom and my sister with their
finances now U my sister has learning
disabilities and I've been following
your plan with her for the past six
years we have her debt free um she has
like
$26,000 in the bank CU she's saving up
to buy a new car not you know like a new
to her car um she has about 29,000 in
retirement just from her work putting in
for her she makes about 27,000 a year
wow what's the nature of her learning
disability it's in math actually so
that's why I do all of her finances for
her okay I'm not I'm not I'm sorry she
she has I'm not aware of an exclusively
math disability what what is this I
don't understand it's not very common um
it's really not a lot of people know
about it she just doesn't understand
Beyond basic like addition subtraction
okay but so that that also inhibits her
career path I assume exactly yes
absolutely okay so and it inhibits her
confidence in applying for a different
job so she has a job she's in now she's
been there for 11 years she's very happy
okay she likes the people she works with
so you've got her in a you've got her in
a sustainable mode way to go yeah you're
a great
sister thank you so um with my dad
passing the situation has arised that my
mom is they were married for 50 years
and she's uncomfortable living on her
own but she really wants to travel and
she doesn't want to leave the house
empty so she came up with the idea that
maybe my sister could move in with her
and cuz she's only going to be there she
only wants to be there for like three
months the year I really want my mom to
live with me to be honest
um
so my sister could sell her house and
make about
$150,000 she has a townhouse she's got
50,000 left on it and we could sell it
for2 does it make sense and there's like
a lot obviously of nuances in here for
her to take that 150 and invest a huge
portion into her retirement because I'm
afraid she's not going to have enough
she's 42 she has this 29,000 in
retirement and she's got some health
issues and my dad passed from health
issues that are genetic and I'm just
worried about taking care of
her what's your mom's house
worth 300 and it's paid off yeah she
doesn't owe anything on it okay all
right
um there's two elements we find from
people that build wealth and are able to
create a sustainable situation at
retirement okay one is a paid for
property and one is a a neste and so
you're you're being very wise in how
you're going at this Indy George yeah so
um I want that for your
sister because if she does not own a
property going into her retirement years
because she moved into your mom's house
and sold hers um she's going to be out
of the real estate game and um that's
what I was nervous about too yeah I'm
worried about that because okay let's
fast forward let's say your sister's uh
life expectancy is better than you fear
and let's say she lives to 70 or 80 okay
at that point the number one line item
in most people's budget expense wise the
largest item is
housing okay and when you have a paid
for property you have greatly reduced
the number one expense
item you've stabilized it like for your
mom in your mom's situation she's
sitting there to paid for $300,000 house
what's that give her
stability yes because she doesn't have
to worry about a stinking house payment
with your dad passing and which might
have forced her to sell the house
instead of thinking about traveling I
don't know I don't know what the rest of
the nest egg is but that that's the
thing so the paid for house that your
mom's sitting on is a beautiful
Testament to your dad and your mom and
how they've managed money that's a
stable thing for your mom going into her
golden years I don't want to take that
away from your
sister okay I I I I is it yeah I just
I'm gonna throw one more wrench into the
situation my mom is saying she's going
to leave the house to both my sister and
myself could my sister just stay in the
house after my mom passes and then that
becomes her house yeah yeah and I I'm
I'm guessing if your mom's traveling 9
months a year there's some money
too there's so I I mean she's
legitimately going to live with me for
six months and I'm beyond happy about
that and my husband is happy that's not
travel no no no but and she has friends
everywhere so and they all want her to
come okay so this is not she's got $2
million in a nest egg and just G to go
out and have some fun unfortunately no
so my question is does she have 300 in
addition to the
house she from what I stand she's got
175 in Investments and then probably 50
in checking but then she gets um pension
and social security enough to cover more
than her bills is it just you and your
sister are you the only two siblings yes
yep here's what I'm beating around I'm
trying to figure out the math that's
fair to you because you've been a
wonderful sister and um I'd like for
your I'd like for your sister to end up
with this house without having to pay
you something
that's honestly it would bring me so
much comfort to know that she's just
taken care of you know like it's okay
and we're in a stable place my husband
and I we're going to be okay we've got
military retirement I'm really worried
that she's so tight on her money and so
tight with her retirement right now and
this would just I mean it would be the
world changing for her as a relationship
part okay with
mom um you hesitated uh my mom is
obviously great I know you I think that
it's I think it's more um an insecurity
for my sister to say I moving back in
with my mom and I told her I was like
it's really mom is living with you you
know if she's living there nine months
of the year and my mom only comes in for
three months just basically to visit and
say hi it's really my mom is gifting her
that house they're changing her
mentality but I understand if you want
to do a if you want to make it thorough
and legal you could sit with an estate
planner and go ahead and deed the house
to your sister with an life estate with
a life estate to your mom meaning your
mom has rights to it as long as she's
alive she could stay there okay and you
could put in the in the in the write up
that your sister's also allowed to
occupy the property um and then your
sister it does own the
house okay that wouldn't be a bad thing
you could sit with an estate planner and
do that under the unified estate tax
exemption uh she could transfer the
title on the property over not pay a
dime on taxes on it
uh your sister could sell the house her
house and dump that money as you said
into retirement no house payment yeah
then that starts to work uh unless your
mom is going to mess up your sister's
progress uh because she's done so well
under your leadership yeah I just keep
coming back to that real estate I like
that she's got skin in the game and I
want her to lose that by the situation
if she's going to own this other house
then that that solves it that keeps her
in the real estate game yeah but I would
also ask what does sister want to
do yeah that's part of it she likes
Independence right now is what I heard
too that's something to deal with that's
a good question and even though it's
quote unquote her house I think
emotionally psychologically and until
the deed has changed over you know
financially I it might be good for your
sister's State of Mind to go ahead and
do the deed with your mom having a life
estate a good official not just a
promise yeah then then this is your
house and you know uh you're getting
your part of the estate now prior to
death and um then the rest of the money
and stuff will come to uh to you
Elizabeth at that point upon death and
it probably won't be 300K is what you're
telling me probably going to be more in
the 200 range depending on what your mom
spends between now and then so
wow I got to tell you Elizabeth that's
very Noble you're you're doing really
good stuff there you're a good person
I'm honored to speak with you I hope we
helped you this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsy Solutions
on the famous debt free stage Sean and
Glenda are with us hey guys how are you
Dave how's it going good to have you
guys hi George where do you guys live
San Antonio Texas oh we love San Antonio
thanks for being with us cool thank you
for having us how much debt did you pay
off about 29
$7,000 how long did that take 5 and2
years about 68 months wow good for you
and your range of income during that
time 86,000 to about
212 wow cool now what kind of debt was
this it's our house Dave you paid your
house look at the weird people we are
weird very weird people love it way to
go you guys what do you'all do for a
living I'm a fire inspector at jbsa Lain
Air Force why aren't you on the radio
with a voice oh my God yeah he does have
a sexy voice well I am on the radio when
I when I have my radio sexy I didn't
radio I said sexy I'm on the fire
department radio so that
counts and I work logistics for um LA
Air Force based oh yeah I'm retired
active duty but I went back as a civil
service ah J thanks for your service
thank you so much appreciate it see paid
off your what's this house worth uh
$44,000 where' it go how much in your
nest egg it's going to be $965,000
[Music]
Milli you mean above the 400 there's 600
something yes so you're right at a
million close oh you're we're about
$40,000 short I just declared it you're
milon way to go thank you appreciate
baby step million check the stock market
in an hour maybe it'll be there how old
are you too 57 57 you got a paid for
house yes sir and you're millionaire yes
and we never owned a house while I was
active duty so that's why took a little
longer to actually say Hey cuz I was
originally from San Anton we both were
yeah I mean I can't believe you wait to
you're 57 to be
rich that's horrible no time like the
present how long how long you guys been
married 32 years yes way to go you way
to go that's so excellent thank you well
done okay so what put you on this
journey five and a half years ago knock
the house out so when I was deployed to
the Middle East which you just came back
from so it's very hot well it shouldn't
have been hot there hot this time but in
the summer it's bad yes when I was there
it was 120° and there was on the
bulletin board for the chapel a Dave
Ramsey Financial Peace course I'm like
well I didn't hear about you about that
time is it air conditioned that's what
we want to know the chapel was car what
the stupid coures is it air conditioned
yes so it started from there and he home
Dave all fired up about getting out of
dead and I wasn't having it uhoh I said
I'm not having this foolishness I'm
going shopping cuz truly I'm the free
spirit he's the nerd apparently but what
he did was he started back then it was
your CDs and he would put the CDs cuz it
actually started in ' 09 that this
happened yeah and we got rid of our Kuma
debt but he started playing the CDs in
the car on the way to work and I like
that it was biblically based and that
you were funny so I said okay I'll go to
the I'll take the class so she took the
class with took it and we never looked
don't like it but it's Jesus and it's
funny yes it's Jesus and it's funny and
uh loved it and we never looked back we
hit it straight head on paid that debt
off and wow moved to San Antonio build a
house and and I think the the budget was
really opened her eyes too yeah the
budget because that made our standard
from never going back into dead again we
cash flowed four cars yeah and
everything else Rec just bought a a car
cash a new to us car it's a 2021 Hamry
but new to us yeah but the that's a
typical millionaire car yeah a
two-year-old cam yeah that's about what
they drive yeah we love it so we just
love that Financial Peace University is
just comprehensive you know it's from
beginning to the end and we also had the
opportunity to um help facilitate to
coordinate with um coordinating the CH
at La
Base well your story has got to inspire
them when you get up there and you share
all of this they've got to be like we're
doing whatever they did our first class
paid off 100 Grand of thatb in the nine
weeks that we taught the class so it was
a uccessful class we were hoping if we
could just help one person that would be
enough for us but 100 Grand was paid off
in our first class wow that's a big
support system in at Lackland that's
great and our and our kids were big
support system wow very cool and we
attend many of your Live Events so we
love the pep rallies it's amazing when
we go to your your Live Events so we've
been to one in San Antonio Houston yeah
Louisville just wherever kind of where
you guys are at we kind follow you
not our first time meeting got a John
deloney
picture this everybody oh my gosh look
at y'all it was awesome way to go you
two how's it feel to be
100% free and millionaires amaz it's
amazing we actually took the picture you
should have put that one in there of our
feet touching the grass yeah but he
didn't have a tan on his feet so it
wasn't a good picture so I had a farmer
tan on my feet so it didn't look good
got a sexy voice but those white white
feet I'm just saying not a foot model no
not at all that's not that's not my side
but but the grass did feel different it
was well you guys have different
decisions now now Glenda the spenda out
here you can actually spend with more
confidence George yes we're going on the
cruise in January so where's the cruise
it's going to go to Honduras and Mexico
yeah very good that's a good Cruise a
good group of friends too so little did
you know you're going to have more fun
spending on the other side you're just
doing it with cash more freedom
everything that's our standard
everything's cash now that we're not
going to go below that stat at all I'm
so proud of yall thank you so much thank
you George and is your family wealthy
did you grow up in wealthy F no not at
all so they all looking at you like
crosseyed yeah yeah we're The Crazy Ones
we're yeah we're weird and weird crazy
and weird trying to bring them along so
a couple of my nephew Sean he's he's
doing real good and your chapl the
chaplain herbs yeah we have a few people
he's the one we're Co coordinating the
Fus class back back home with yes which
is great cuz it makes you want to do it
too oh yeah everybody's watching it's
contagious it is it's it's funny that
just working your butt off and living on
less than you make is now considered
weird like I don't understand you're not
just spending other people's money how
does that work czy you're not
irresponsible you're weird exactly cuz
that's the opinion we get sometimes
where you can't do that you can't buy a
car cash I'm like well I did it kind of
just did for the fourth time to argue
with that yeah exactly what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of dead
is well I tell them to take FPU I like
you I do I say take FPU U the budget
zero based budget not just the budget
cuz for years we did a budget we paid
extra on everything never got anywhere
with that but doing it your way the zero
based would is what did it for us and um
cuz I re emphasized that in the FPU
course I said your personal budget's
Your Truth your your budget's not going
to lie to you your your income what you
put into your budget is what you're
going to be able to do how to get out of
debt how to pay for items things that
pop up that you
you it's an emergency that happens but
you're ready for it it's part of
inconvenience when we had an emergency
which we had several we we cash flow a
couple of helped with funerals yeah we
both of our moms passed away within the
last year so it wasn't a crisis to plan
the funeral it was just we just did it
we didn't have to worry about you know
where are we going to get the money for
cuz funerals are a racket if you look at
it terrible yeah we just took care of
business basically cuz since we had
enough funds to take care of it we don't
have to worry about stuff changes a for
roof we get a roof replacement roof time
roof repair cash so life's still going
to hit you but you just got to be
prepared for it that's what you go
through their class you get it got man
this I'm ready to pay off some debt and
I don't have
any way to go you two hey we've got the
live and give box for you it's another
FPU membership you'll be able to give
that to somebody cuz you're being such a
blessing thank you Total Money Makeover
book and baby steps millionaires book
which you're you're all of that we're so
proud of y'all well done sha and Glenda
San Antonio Texas 297,000 paid off house
and everything that's a $4,000 house and
almost 700 600 some change in the old uh
in the old retirement so that's making
them baby steps millionaires they did
all of this in 5 and A2 years making 80
to 212 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream 3 2 1 we're
[Music]
[Applause]
free love it this is the ramsy
[Music]
shot
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host Cassie's in Denver hi Cassie how
are you doing well how are you better
than I deserve what's
up um so my husband and I are on baby
step two um in the process of off our
debts and um we discovered before we got
married that um my husband had about
$117,000 in student debt um to kind of
explain the situation his parents agreed
in when they got divorced to pay for
their kids college tuition um so at the
start of each semester my husband's mom
would send him cash and his dad would
ask that he take out a loan in my
husband's name that his dad um verbally
agreed to pay back at the end of um
College basically so um my husband also
worked full-time 40 hours he ended up
getting all of his tuition
reimbursed that at the end of each
semester he would send his mom the cash
back and his dad the other half and he
thought he was paying those loans off
but come to find out he spent that money
instead and now my husband still has
$177,000 in student loans in his name
with his dad's verbal agreement to pay
it back well I think we see why they got
a
divorce yes is one of the many reasons
um that he's poor with money but we are
not that he borrows money that he steals
money from his kids I mean what kind of
guy is
this yeah and it's kind of hit to the
point where we really we're in the we
have a four-month old we want to
purchase a house soon um the question is
you know is that debt fall on us or your
husband's yeah exact and so do we delay
buying the house to pay that off yes
okay I'm
sorry I'm guess I'm guessing your
father-in-law I mean this guy sounds
like a real upstanding
twerp um I'm guessing he doesn't have
$177,000 to honor his word and pay this
off right uh he lives paycheck to
paycheck and probably will for the rest
of his life yeah and for some reason we
just trusted that he was going to go
through with this whole deal but your
husband did all this when he was a kid
he gave your dad I mean he's a he's a
college kid right yeah I mean you're
1718 your parents finances are your
finances yeah he well he so he sent him
the he sent him the money back then he
didn't sent money since y'all been
married correct he sent him the money at
the end of each semester long timeo
being paid off yeah yeah so what's your
household
income uh about 116 how much money do
you
have um right now we have you mean like
in savings M um so we have our th000
emergency fund and then we're just
paying off our other debts including so
you have you're working a Deb
snowball yes M I'm sorry Cassie how much
are the Deb if you guys
got um so I have about 12,000 students
and then I have 23,000 on a car I'm
actively trying to sell it and get a
lesser car and he has about 10,000 on
his truck that we've been snowballing so
okay well I'm guessing
that this
pattern of lack of integrity and
irresponsibility has already put a
strain on your husband's relationship
with his dad not counting not counting
this here if you just took this out it
was already a
strain no they haven't my husband was
pretty clueless until I got in the
picture he didn't you know he he's he's
of the mindset it's his dad's
responsibility It Was Written in no no
no no no you misunderstand me yeah your
your your husband's dad is a
twerp okay the student loans not the
first time he was a twerp correct yes so
I'm guessing that his dad your dad your
husband is already strained just because
his dad doesn't do the stuff he says
he's going to do in general correct yes
he's in you're right he has done this
before he I mean he says he's going to
be there for Christmas he doesn't come
or he says he's going to be there at six
o'clock he comes at 10 o00 cuz he just
doesn't the world revolves around him it
doesn't occur to him that he's supposed
to keep his word on
anything Y and that's why they're not
married anymore I mean that's you know
so what what I'm pointing out is is the
student loan is just a one more Brick in
the Wall o of this guy's life it's cuz
it's very seldom that you'd have this as
a standalone issue in his life in in the
father-in-law's life so my point is yeah
put it in you you you owe it legally
you're going to have to pay it it's not
going to go away until youall pay it so
put it in your debt snowball I'm so
sorry you're having to do that but then
what you all need to do is step back and
if I'm in your shoes this pisses me off
a
lot M cuz it delays when you get your
house a
little and I
would require that um if I'm you I
require is not the right word I
would want uh my spouse to say out loud
how bad this is and not just act like
this is okay if your husband act like
this is okay it's going to make you
really angry this is not okay this is
not okay does he still trust that his is
going to pay this I don't understand yes
yes he does and he did it for his sister
as well and she he's actually miss
payments on her plan so her credit got
really messed up from it there's nothing
in the entire story that indicates he's
ever going to pay this yeah and so your
husband owning that is going to help you
relationally with your husband and help
you emotionally if I'm in your shoes
this is me anyway it's going to help me
if my wife if this is my wife and she
came in she goes look this is awful I'm
so sorry we got to pay this and it's
wrong and he's not going to do it I wish
he would do it I just He's Just Not That
guy he's the guy that doesn't do what he
says he's going to do he's that guy and
so it it that's for you and your husband
because there's nothing either one of
y'all are going to is going to change
the twerp the twerp's just a
twerp he just is I mean he's just over
there and you're not going to change him
and no amount of angry is going to make
there's no justice in this story mhm
Justice will not be done in this story
this side of heaven right cuz Justice
would be the old man paid the
bill right but that's nobody in
this within the airshot of our
microphones right now 30 million people
listening this call none of them think
he's going to pay the bill your
husband's the only
one so he needs to own that for the sake
of your all's relationships you what I'm
saying does that make sense to you yes
it does you know I'm not asking him to
disown his father or never speak to him
again I'm not suggesting that there's
not molestation or something that's
occurred here there's nothing like that
this is just the old man didn't keep his
word well yeah that happens a lot I'm
I'm afraid the old lady didn't keep her
word that happens a lot I'm afraid so
but you can love him where you know he's
just that guy over there and it's just I
just love him in his but I'm certainly
not going to do any business with this
guy ever again I'm not going to trust
him with any money not going to send any
money to him you know you're $177,000 in
the hole to me let's just start the
conversation there yeah but so the
reality is you guys are earn 62,000 of
debt your debt you make 116 and this is
a solvable problem it's but it's going
to delay your home purchase by a few
years well not even but maybe 18 months
is what it's going to take to get rid of
all this debt unless you sell the car it
will happen even sooner so yeah yeah
it's um you're going to get there you're
going to get there it's just but it's
like you got scammed is what it feels
like scammed I'm out the money and I
didn't just get scammed I got scammed by
my dad yeah oh my God the person is
supposed to love me one that's supposed
to not it's like these parents that
steal their kids identity it's a certain
level of scum it's a whole another level
of scum when you steal your own kid's
identity and you go open accounts in
your kids name oh my God that's just
this guy didn't do that but he he's just
he's in the same bucket you know and
it's just awful oh I'm so sorry but the
the the problem is when we get into
these things you get right down to the
facts the facts are Cassie that your
husband has a student loan in his
name and no one's going to pay it if
y'all don't so you're in debt so you got
to clean it up that's the facts but the
emotion around the facts is just nasty
well the whole situation from the
beginning just sounded complicated and
sketchy they was like well you take the
down your name and I'll I'll get you you
make the yeah once you say that right
there you you can see what's coming if
Dad's not willing to take out the loan
for himself he wasn't willing to take on
the risk and he was not willing to to
pay well yeah he didn't have the money
and he doesn't now he blew it somehow
and Mom's over here handing cash and
he's handing her cash back oh my gosh
and yeah you can tell what happened tell
what happened to that marriage that's
just awful
yeah yeah Integrity shows up in
everything and it shows up it always
shows up as a pattern not a singular
event and that's what you're looking for
that's why I was saying that about it
wasn't the first time and it won't be
the last no no it's not going to be the
last time he doesn't keep his word on
something
that's the problem stinks
ouch ouch some people's parents this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
w
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships the phone number here is
8825 5225 YouTube sensation George camel
is my co-host today Ramsey personality
he's also the co-host of the uh smart
money happy hour and uh we appreciate
you guys joining us today open phones
Merry Christmas to you thanks for
hanging out and George um you and Rachel
got my wife to do something I can't get
her to do what's that go on a podcast we
we got there first you got there she
I've not been I mean she did this show
30 years ago one time when there were
four people listening to it oh my
goodness but um I after that she won't
come back on yeah it was the honor of a
lifetime for Sharon Ramsey to agree to
do smart money happy hour I cornered her
at last year's Christmas party and she's
a big fan of the podcast and I said well
Sharon you should be on it and she said
I'll do it and that was it that was and
then you all sent her all the positive
comments from YouTube none of the
negatives well there was and so now she
thinks she's a star there was weirdly
only positive comments Dave even in the
YouTube comment section which is
generally a cesspool everybody's like we
love Sharon she needs to be a third
co-host she's America's sweetheart wow
so she's a star they love her Sharon if
you're listening which you're not
listening to this show you're busy
listening to Smart money happy hour so
we W have to worry about her head
getting too big but it was a great
episode so I encourage you guys go check
out the smart money Happy Hour episode
featuring The One and Only Sharon Ramsey
Courtney's in Canada hi Courtney welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave and George can you hear me
all right we can how are you oh I'm
doing all right I am so honored to talk
to you guys I'm very excited we're glad
to have you Christmas um I have a
question um I'll tell you my question
I'll give you a little bit of background
so I am wondering what I should do with
my rental excuse me my rental property
income I uh moved in with my fiance and
so my house was empty I tried to sell it
it was on the market for about a year
and no luck so um I decided for the
winter season to uh get a renter and so
now I have this extra income from a
renter and I'm just wondering if I
should put it towards I'm in baby step
two I'm wondering if I should be
throwing it towards um my debt snowball
or if I should be um saving a portion of
that in case um worst case scenario and
I have to do repairs on the
house
yes a little bit of both yeah you need
you need you need an emergency fund for
the house because as a landlord one of
the things you're going to discover is
owning real estate's not
cheap and so you're going to have to
have some what we would in business we'd
call it retained to earnings uh in
Ramsey talk we call it an emergency fund
right where you've got some money set
aside so when the water heater goes out
you've got to fix it you got to ten it
yeah so if you if you have zero money
and something breaks over there you're
screwed
right yeah and I have I have a very good
income um I'm just obviously what is
your very good income I make about 150
that's nice good for you good for you I
still I still would set aside like
what's your rent on this place
income um I charge 2,000 a month and my
it it cost me1 1850
okay it costs you $1850 well my mortgage
is $1850 a month and and I'm charging my
$2,000 yeah so this is a money-making
scheme of 1,00 bucks it's $150 we're
discussing here yes um the market is
it's a very small town I know but I
don't think $150 is going to change your
life either way here what really is
going to change your life you get this
property sold um and I sure hope you're
married by then when you're getting
married uh June 7th 25 we are working
separately on our uh on our debt and we
are paying we're cash flowing the
wedding so we decided to give it a year
and a
half it's going to take you a year and a
half to cash flow a
wedding well to get rid of our debt and
then cash flow our wedding we can you
scale down the wedding and just get the
wedding knocked out and be married and
then knock this debt out
together um I mean we could we just with
your very good
income yes
um yeah we could do that I don't know if
the world's going to be around in 2025 I
don't want to be married to this guy
like I guess that's silly because like I
we both know we're going to spend the
rest of our lives together and we want a
really nice wedding it's it's nothing
crazy it's only well I mean it's average
it's 20,000 so um we just thought like
if we get all our money in order first
and then we can save I plan to be debt
free by April or May and then get some
time to plan and all that stuff
okay um sell your house as soon as
possible and if I woke up in your shoes
you can do whatever you want to do
you're grown people okay uh but having
having lived um and sat with people in
uh where things didn't turn out like
they thought they were going to um if I
were in your all shoes I would put my
dead snowballs on hold temporarily what
does your fiance
make he makes about 150 to 160 okay so
you have $300,000 you're playing with
stop everything and put 20 grand
together and go get married
now like March okay that's what I would
do I would you could put a wedding
together by March and go get married and
then start then take your $300,000
income and clean up your your debt we
don't tell people that they should be
debt free before getting married but
they should be in agreement about doing
that before after during whatever you
should be in agreement about your money
but you don't have to be debt free to
prove it to each other um and you're
just you're in a
very uh you're taking a lot of risk here
that you don't even realize you're
taking uh let's say you sell this house
and then something goes
sideways um yeah you got a mess on your
hands kiddo so yeah you guys need to
decide what you're going to do and let's
go ahead and get things in the right
order here and you do whatever you want
to do but that's what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes knowing that I
know I'm not waiting 2 and 1/2 years to
get get married to do to do this I'm
with George on this I'm I'm going to put
it together I would put the dead
snowball on hold temporarily quickly I
mean you could what two months you get
20 grand yeah I mean with 300 Grand they
only need to put in 10 grand each and
this thing's done yeah that's a paycheck
that's really not not hard yeah and so
um and then let's get rid of this house
cuz this house is a burden as soon as
you're married uh so you march the house
goes on the market right after we get
married that's if I woke up in your
shoes that's what I would I want to know
why I didn't sell for a whole year that
part is uh
interesting she said it's a rural area
not a lot of market so she wasn't able
to rent it though for 2,000 bucks so
it's an interesting thing that's tough
but yeah some of these rentals Dave we
get the call in we always ask them well
how much are you making well after the
mortgage it makes we make about 100
bucks a month and I go for 1,200 bucks a
year I'd rather just go do a side Hustle
No that's a lot of risk that's a whole
lot of risk and that's if everything
goes perfectly and it never goes
perfectly it's called rental property I
mean it just doesn't go perfectly
something is always busted people don't
pay I mean stuff is always and they
don't treat it like their own house no
it's it's a it's a thing man and so yeah
you
just the longer you leave a renter in
there um the harder you're going to be
to get rid of this property without
spending some more money on it so um
yeah I'm I really think I would do those
things you do whatever you want to do
but you guys have got great potential
and you're dragging the stuff out to
your own Peril putting your life on hold
for this 150 bucks a month it's not
worth it yeah exactly this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Kevin
and ginger are with us hey guys how are
you great can't complain Dave welcome
good to have you where do you guys live
uh Cleveland Ohio fun welcome to
Nashville how much debt have you paid so
we paid off
$120,000 cool how long did that take
about 28 months good for you yes and
your range of income during that time so
it was 78,000 and then all the way up to
138,000 cool what do youall do for a
living so I'm an accountant and then I
do cyber security as well ah good and
I'm also an accountant and then do
auditing wow great careers way to go
guys thanks so what kind of debt was the
120,000 so we uh paid off our
house couple weirdos yeah I love it
what's the house worth uh the last time
I checked it was 220 so wow 220 in
Cleveland
Ohio and how old are you two I'm 28 and
Kevin's 30 I'm 30 28 did you say yes 28
and 30 and you have paid for house worth
a quarter million dollars
yeah I love it way to go you two thank
you so how long you've been married
three years okay so right after you got
married you look at this and go this is
doable we're a couple of accountants we
can do math we can pay this house 100%
yes we can pay this house off so how did
you get connected to Ramsay so my
mother-in-law was like hey there's this
guy this old guy kind of like your
grandpa I know I know that's what she
said is she blame it on the
Mother-in-law she's uh 62 but no she was
like you I know you're really attached
to your grandpa and he's kind of like
him so you should look at him and kind
of be guided with what he is going to
say so I'm like all right so I got a
couple like YouTube videos I'm like man
this guy is he does Finance super simple
and everybody can understand it so I'm
just like I'm going to go full on just
gazelle intense on all any kind of debt
so that's pretty much the whole thing so
C uh Ginger you're like my mother what
did she
do i' be like you keep sending them
YouTube links what are you
doing I love it so were you on board
Ginger did this all make sense to you
we're like all right sure like that
sounds fun what a cool goal oh yeah yeah
I was like let's get this done and
that's how you do it in 28 months
120,000 that's impressive well like
school was always like Leverage and all
that stuff and like fancy you know
trying to like time the market and all
that stuff and I'm like well or we could
just pay off everything and then just
not have to worry about anything for the
rest of our lives that's a strategy
that's a strategy I'm going with that
one I like that I'm going with the peace
and calmness I like this this is good
good way to go so your mother-in-law's
got to be happy yes oh yes oh yes she
was like the first like big cheerer
she's like holy crap you did it yes I
love it well congratulations you guys
how's it feel to be 30 years old not
have a payment in the world y are feels
feels pretty good feels pretty good I
mean I know what's it called we both had
a goal when we got married I'm like all
right we need to do this before we're 30
and I missed it by one month I missed it
by one month but it was okay it was okay
I was like I would call such a way to be
a failure I'm just
saying did you have friends that were
cheering you guys on do they know about
this or was this kind of a private thing
oh they thought we were crazy they were
like you make all this money and you're
not getting a Tesla and I'm like cuz I I
want a Tesla but I'm like man it's just
so
expensive right I know like I know
you're in the Tesla all the time and I'm
like man I want one of those but like
I'll did the here's what I did though I
waited till the house was paid off and
then I bought a very used Tesla that
didn't hurt my stomach for such a thing
as a junky Tesla
that's not that's not on fire George has
one that's it it hasn't burned down yet
Dave yeah so a lot exciting yeah a lot
of our friends got like new appliances
and new stuff for our housing and you
know they always are upscaling their
lifestyle and then here's us with our
200 you know 10 Ford Escape just like
you know it's good you know but it's not
great but we just thought well if we're
just defree and have that good journey
it's just you know we'll have peace for
you'll be driving like no one else soon
my friends exct 140k with no payments so
now that you're
free are you two weirdos going to
lighten up and go do something cool so
that Segways us great so as soon as we
promised ourselves that we would buy a
luxury hot tub that I did give an image
to them but a luxury hot tub after we
paid off and we did indeed buy the
hot
touchdown all right that's better than a
Tesla it won catch I know I was like you
know Tesla hot Tu I was like well I get
to relax all day then I'm telling you
yeah that's a lot better that's a lot
better H it's fireproof way to go man
thank you excellent that's cool I love
it good for you guys you guys are on
you're on track to be multi-millionaires
you going be able to do anything you
want to do you'll be able to be generous
with money you'll be able to change your
whole family tree pretty incredible and
all CU your uh mother who's my age said
there's this old guy that was the most
offensive part like she's his age this
doesn't make sense I know I was like
he's not even that bad but compared to
you she was saying Hey listen I get he's
not as young strapping his she was
talking about relative to you I get it
I'm not mad it's funny it's funny hey
thanks guys so proud of y'all what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is follow a budget stick to it
check check in on your budget have your
cheerleaders with you I I think make you
got to make sure that you hold yourself
accountable too right you know you just
got to make sure that like if you're
with a relationship or partner they make
sure that you're accountable and they're
accountable too um but if you're sing I
Got a Feeling both of you guys were
pretty dial in from doesn't sound like
were do sound like anybody was kicking
and screaming yeah when we went to
marriage counseling cuz we did that also
my mother-in-law said you should do that
so I'm like okay when we went to
marriage counseling they did like this
test or whatever I don't know and then
for the finance section it was literally
I I I couldn't even believe it we were
in the opposite rooms 100% we we were
100% aligned with that I was like what
so that's a Les parrots test oh that's
right the simus simus simus yeah yeah
yeah that's a great test save your
marriage before it starts exactly that's
a great test wow that's what happens
when two Finance Nerds come together and
they're actually aligned look at what
you guys can accomplish and what happens
is they're going to be so rich so cool
way to go you two well done hey we've
got the live and give box for you it has
in it the baby steps millionaires book
which is where you're going for sure uh
The Total Money Makeover book you've got
that memorized and uh Financial Peace
University membership to give to one of
your doubting friends and uh that's
right you can get them going in the
right direction now so this is stuff for
you to live and stuff for you to give
our way of saying thanks for coming down
from Cleveland to let us celebrate with
you we're proud of you we're proud of
your mother-in-law we're proud of
everybody way to go you guys you're in
such great shape pretty incredible hot
tub so tub hot tub was not on my bingo
card but I love it well played
Kevin and ginger Cleveland Ohio 120,000
paid off in 28 months house and
everything not even 30 did it in making
78 to 138 count it down let's hear a
debt-free Scream 3 2 1 we're de
[Applause]
free yeah love it way to go you guys
way to go that's impressive what I love
is that 28 months of sacrifice is what
it took and the next 28 years are
drastically different 38 48 years and
most people would rather just live in
mediocrity for 28 years and not do this
that's what's crazy to me they'll just
sort of stumble through life and wake up
28 months from now going yeah we're
still broke still got the same money
stress but if you're just willing to
sacrifice for this short period of time
this is a blip in the scale of your life
changes everything you know we had uh my
old friend Art Williams speak at entree
leadership and he used to say you're
going to pay a
price period everyone is going to pay a
price you're going to pay a price now
living like no one else like they did so
that later you can live and give like no
one else or you're going to pay a price
of living a whole life like you said the
money fights medoc never Building Wealth
a whole life of mediocrity a whole life
of financial stress you'll be normal
God help you don't be normal people
that's why when someone does this we
yell hey weirdo cuz it's weird to pay
off your house it's weird to be a
grownup and live on less than you make
it's weird normal is
broke stressed out freaked out number
one cause a divorce in North America
today money fights money problems that's
normal you don't want to be normal
normal sucks this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
w
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I am Dave Ramsey your host
thank you for doing this I've been doing
this radio show taking calls uh for
those of you listening on podcast or
watching on YouTube this started with
and is still a talk radio show uh it's
on 680 radio stations the second largest
Talk Radio Show in America that's how
this whole thing started been doing it
for over 30 years now and during that 30
years I've taken uh some wild calls some
funny calls some sad calls um we've
taken calls but you know what we don't
do a good job of here because it's just
not the format it's not what we're here
for is we don't ever get the opportunity
very often to follow up and go back and
say did you do what I told you to do
were you able to turn it around did it
turn out okay how'd this work out when
did you follow the advice was the advice
good you know were we able to help you
we don't ever follow up and find out
later sometimes we hear a little bit of
that with a Deb free scream
George but where are they now yeah but
it's kind of where where are they now
stuff we you know we just uh help you
and you go on your way and your friends
know what happened your family knows
what happened in some cases but uh um
but you know we don't bring you back on
here and do that so we're going to
change that today because on August 1st
we took a call from
Sarah and uh she was in a
pickle uh we've got an edited quick
version of the call just to give you an
idea and then we'll recap it so James is
going to fire that let's hear it I'm
kind of in a financial crisis and I'm
not really sure what to do my house is
in the process of being foreclosed on oh
my and I don't know if I should just
throw in the towel fight I lost my
husband 4 years ago and we've been
surviving off the Social Security and
insurance payments what
happened he was working for a roofing
company and he fell through a skylight
working on a roof 30
feet oh my I'm so sorry and um he
suffered a cerebral hemorrhage and the
the insurance company that was what
workers comp or liability insurance for
the for the employer says they're not
liable yeah they filed an appeal and you
have an
attorney I have one through um workman's
comp and they have denied the appeal and
restarted my
payments but that put me in a place
where I got behind really behind and
then by the time I got a job I was I was
drowning yeah you are not getting four
closed
on
breathe I know how to stop I mean I know
this is my fault it's it's not your
fault nope no it's not your fault life
has happened to you you've had a tragedy
honey so you're you're in good you're
okay now do we have some problems that
we need to address
yes okay we do but you're not going to
lose this house I'm 100% sure of it okay
my car got repoed last month
okay all right how are you uh do you
have a car at all no okay all right and
so you don't have anybody around you in
family and and things do you I lost my
father 6 months before I lost my husband
okay how many how many kids you
got four so here's what we're going to
do okay we're going to wrap our arms
around you and make sure you're okay and
we're going to put a bunch of people in
your life and um you're we going to
follow the instructions of these people
and we're going to save your house and
we're going to get you back up on your
feet and get you a car and get you going
again
okay okay all right we got we've got
ramsy counselors right here in your town
we we're in your town and we'll use one
of our on staff people to take care of
you okay her her name is Lisa and
Austin's going to hook you up with her
and she's going to get in touch with the
mortgage company and um this is taken
care of we're going to take care of
it so that's a quick grasp of what the
call was a little longer than that but
her husband passed away at 36 years old
uh as as she said in a roofing accident
and the insurance company quit paying
the payment she only owed $64,000 on the
houses worth 375,000 it was $45 days
from foreclosure when she called on
August the
1st um so that's a lot of equity I mean
she had a $300,000 worth the equity that
she was going to lose on that
foreclosure um she' just gotten theob
making about $20 an hour uh she was 5
months behind on a $600 house payment
$3,000 no car cuz she like she said her
car got repoed no family around her
except her four kids um which are 201
178 and six um wasn't plugged into her
church in her community um and we sat
her down with our our top counselor the
lady that runs our whole counseling area
Lisa Barber and um Lisa stepped in in
and began to guide everything through
this situation cuz we knew we deal with
this stuff every day and we knew exactly
how
to uh pull this off well what happened
in the meantime was God showed up
miraculously a roofing company in the
area heard this and said uh well that's
not okay and they wrote the check and
Lisa got with the mortgage company and
caught the payments up sto the
Foreclosure the $33,000 or whatever it
was to get the 4,000 with legal fees
whatever it was to get the house caught
up and so the house is not in
foreclosure like I told her she's not
going to lose that house um not for
three grand my God you know not going to
happen so this other company heard the
story and stepped in and was generous
and another guy that listens to the show
all the time in her area that's been a
fan for years um purchased a car and
handed her the
case um so she got a good used car got
her house current Lisa was able to sit
down with her and with the insurance
payments reactivated and the budget
going um she's able to get a hold on
this
um the you
know this turned around so we've got
Sarah on the line let's bring her up and
check on her now Sarah how are you hey
Dave how are you I'm doing great you
sound a little different than the last
time I talked to you I do I feel
different I gotta tell you Lisa Barber
Lisa Barber is a huge sarahan all she
can tell me over and over and over again
is how tough you are and how resilient
you are and how you can fight through
anything I don't think I would make it
without Lisa she is a godsend none of us
would we have that's why we have a Lisa
yeah she's forever a part of my family
like it or
not so the house is current you got a
car the job how's everything else going
it's it's going I mean um in the
beginning it took me some time it's
taken me some time I I set my
expectations for myself a little too
high and thought Oh I can just write it
all down and I'll get it right overnight
and I'm good to go and I didn't realize
how much those behaviors have to be
unlearned and that I didn't really think
about that in the beginning and I kept
getting it wrong the first couple of
months and I can't make it work and I
don't know what I'm doing wrong and one
day I would be like okay I can't do this
I give up and I'm like no there's no
room for failure here we can't do this
we've been severely blessed immensely
favored and I cannot I can't let this
happen again so I mean it took me some
time I'm still I'm still getting there
we're still turning this ship around but
it's definitely been different and um
you guys I can't I just can't thank you
if it wasn't for you guys just taking my
call like my whole world was safe sa d
by so many
people it's an impressive story of
generosity the people that were inspired
by you to come around you I I just I
stand back and watch the all that
because we didn't write any checks out
of ramsy we just provided Lisa's help um
and the knowledge the knowledge base
does it but um but the the generosity in
the community and you're the kind of
people people like to help you know uh
people that people that got the grit in
their belly you're you're a lady there
not going to quit like you said it's
just not an option no it's not I mean
these kids need me and they need me to
get it right and they need me to do it
right and teach them right and I I don't
have a choice well we love you we're
here with you we appreciate you you're
an amazing lady so you keep it up and
thanks for letting us follow up with you
we're proud of your journey and uh proud
of where it's taking you anyway I'm
sorry for how you got here but proud of
where you are our team is cheering you
on and so is America and wead glad to
hear you're doing better amen this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day James 15 if any
of you likes wisdom let him ask God who
gives generously to all without reproach
and it will be given to him Charlie
Munger says it is remarkable how much
long-term Advantage People Like Us have
gotten by trying to be consistently not
stupid instead of trying to be
intelligent George that's like right up
the alley of your whole YouTube show oh
absolutely if you'll just not be stupid
you have a you have a Marketplace
Advantage absolutely and Charlie Munger
uh rest his soul passed away recently
but man that advice is timeless so I'm
still using it today just trying to help
people avoid the stupid those clips of
him and Moren Buffett together sitting
and talking are fabulous they're so
brilliant and they have so much wit yeah
they're just well they're dry they don't
there it's like two old man Muppets
that's what it reminds me of it's pretty
funny the two guys in the balcony but
but with a lot of lot more wisdom
Statler and Waldorf yeah a lot lot more
wisdom than the Muppet Muppet yeah but
yeah they they're just they just don't
give that's classic old men don't give a
rip you I can't wait to get there let me
know how it is Dave when you're there
don't care what you think I've been
there since I was a young guy I don't
care what you think kind of lost the
need for that started it early Max is in
Boston hey Max welcome to the ramsy
show thank you for having me excited to
be here uh just last week blew through
total bunny makeover in just like two
days and it really spoke to me and I've
realized that I just I have tracked all
my like spending for the last almost
nine months since the beginning of March
I have absolutely no
idea how to just go about like the right
behaviors like I see it and I feel like
I'm not saving enough money that I need
to be for my future goals like I know I
want to buy an engagement ring for my
girlfriend I know that I want to start
doing those next kind of things in life
and I'm just not I feel like I'm behind
but I feel like I'm not in a terrible
spot I just need just D some like how to
navigate money I
guess how old are
you uh just turned 30 in October well
the good good news is you got plenty of
time to reroute this ship so what is
your current Financial picture do you
have much
debt uh I have 12 you know
$1,200 uh with no interest for a
mattress I got a couple years ago that's
it that's it so 1,200 bucks would get
you completely debt free but you're
living paycheck to paycheck you're are
you making good money what's your
income my income all my gross income for
this year will be
91,000 wow but I'm still yeah do you
have anything in the bank ofing yeah I
got um I got 1,300 in checking 8500 in
savings 29,000 in a
401k uh I was very lucky even had a
grandma who left some money behind so I
have
72,500 in investment account and then
3,000 some crypto and so that's that's
what I'm working with well you got
plenty of money
yeah I I still just stress the beauty
you read the total your makeover so let
me tell you those baby steps they work
as long as you don't think you're unique
or special and need to mess with them it
works and so you already have a th000
bucks you have the money and savings to
pay off the mattress today let's get
that out of your head it's living
rentree in your head right now it is so
get that out of the picture now we can
work on a fully funded emergency fund
which you could have very quickly making
91,000 you already have a good start
take some out of the investment account
create the emergency f you already have
it sitting
there so you're in you're in baby steps
four five and six if you move some money
around cat cash in the crypto pay off
the mattress build your emergency fund
out of the money that you've got it for
your fingertips if you can't quite get
there on the 3 to six months use a
little bit of the investment money and
move it in there and um go that route
you know and then you're at baby step
four start investing 15% of your income
into retirement do you own a home
yet no no I rent okay you thinking about
buying a
house I don't think I'll be ready for
that for a few years I think what does
ready mean emotionally or
financially financially okay why you
make plenty of
money I'm I'm not really saving a ton
I'm paying 1,900 in rents uh my total
like living expenses about
2500 what's your take home pay
take home I think it's going to be get
rid some math about
58718 for this year so you can save
3,000 bucks a
month in one year that's
36,000 with some of the money you've got
from your grandmother you've got enough
for a good down payment in a
year so I should use that on a down
payment and not just let it ride in some
of it yeah the problem is Max you're
just doing a lot at once and they're all
good things savings great investing is
great paying off debt is great but when
you do it with some Focus intensity like
the mattress has gone tomorrow all right
next up we got to get the emergency fund
great we got that let's invest 15% then
you've got some margin and you have a
focused goal and so beyond the 15% it's
let's get the engagement ring let's work
on the down payment fund the engagement
ring crypto will do that yeah hey there
you go it's a good trade good trade fake
money for a girl that's a good trade do
you want a wife or do you want some
ethereum that's that's the call to make
here
Max I'm gonna choose the thing that's
real and not the thing that some guy
made
up you're Max you're on your way George
is right if you'll take the stuff from
The Total Money Makeover and follow it
straight through it'll give you a sense
of power because you've got a
step-by-step plan laid out there it also
sounds like you need to probably do a
detailed budget and then give yourself
permission to walk these steps um
somehow it it sounds like um you're you
you don't feel like that this is all
possible it's very possible with the
math you gave us but part of it is you
have to start taking the actions based
on that you start to believe that it's
possible and when you start taking those
actions uh pay off the mattress get rid
of the crypto get the emergency fund in
place get the ring um you know then take
a year and let's save up the money for
down payment um during that time you're
probably going to get married that'd be
awesome then you got two incomes to save
towards the down payment on the house
and you'll in really really good shape
at that point that's that's where I
would take you so Josephine is in
Brooklyn hi Josephine welcome to the
ramsy
show Hi how are you better than I
deserve what's up oh I'm in a little
limbo here so um I was watching your
show off and on you know it work but
then I was home working from home this
day and I watching your show where you
was talking about um uh old debt when uh
you go into debt when you have a debt
and uh you don't pay pay it off and they
go into collections and what they do is
they pay a penny on the dollar so um I
uh took a payday loan out um probably 13
years ago May a little longer yeah and
uh all of that time never heard was so I
was working for a company that went out
of business so all the email and all
that got got blasted so I probably owed
maybe another $200 on it uh and I you
know was waiting for them to contact me
they didn't not making an excuse so I
didn't pay it so uh in September of this
year I got a call from a law office
saying that that loan now was $4,000
something dollar and they could settle
it out of court for uh about
$3,200 so for the fact is that I'm
actually saving for a home and I want to
you know uh not have any increase on my
uh my credit report because I worked
hard to build up my credit I paid them
and now I'm getting another call back
from another Law Firm saying that that
the what I paid them did not cover the
law fees and now they're asking me for
another 27 so you did not get it in
writing that 3200 paid the
account I have uh what do they call it
OCR I have something saying yes that it
was that I do have something in writing
saying that this settles the account I
do have something tell the tell the
other law firm to stick
it you you have you have bill you have a
bill in your hand that says paid in
full on an old bad debt for 3,200 bucks
you overpaid on that but you gave them
$3,200 and they gave you a piece of
paper that says you paid the bill in
full am I right well no they they they
sent me so I this is what I did I sent
an email for an o saying that this is
amount will is for the debt and this uh
this settles the debt yes it does say
this settles the debt it settles the
debt so so that they this is a scam just
tell them to bite it not a chance I'm
giving them a dime nope good luck with
that yeah yeah I'm
sorry oh people people people people
payday lenders scum of the earth scum of
the
earth that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
n
for